- About three weeks ago I said
you'll know that
there's some tension,
or a little bit of elbow room,
when you start seeing
background quotes
from somebody close
to the White House,
or within the White House,
who says something about Kamala
Harris that would make it
clear that she is
the Vice President.
- [Dave] Mhm.
- And so when I saw that,
I'm like, ooh. To me,
that was kind of like,
it was kind of the
first time you had seen
a little bit of a
brush back pitch,
and I don't know what's
going on internally
because you'd never see anybody.
They don't talk, they
don't do anything.
But that was definitely a
little bit of a just remember.
And also, if I
were Kamala Harris,
I'd be mad.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin
and joining me today
is a former White House
press secretary
to George W. Bush,
co-anchor of America's Newsroom,
and cohost of The
Five on Fox News,
and author of the new book,
Everything Will Be Okay,
Life lessons for young women
from a former young woman.
Dana Perino, welcome
back to The Rubin Report.
- Honored to be here,
thanks for having me.
- You are a busy lady,
and before we get to
any of that busy stuff,
most importantly, how
is your dog Jasper?
I could do just an hour on
dogs and Jasper with you.
How's he doing?
- It's actually one of the ways
that you and I first
connected, right?
It was dogs,
and I see that great
picture of Clyde.
Is that Clyde there in
the picture behind you?
- That's that's actually
Emma over there--
- [Dana] That was Emma.
Okay, yep.
- But they look
bizarrely similar,
which is a total coincidence.
- I remember when Clyde
came into your life,
it was like, wait,
this is perfect.
You weren't anticipating,
and you weren't planning it,
but it all worked out great.
So Jasper's great.
He is going to be nine in April.
In late January, he came out
of the bedroom one morning,
and was walking real strange,
tail down, hair up.
Obviously you know your dog,
you know something's wrong,
but unfortunately they
can't tell you what's wrong.
So we took him to the vet.
They did a check.
There was a small tumor,
a malignant tumor, on
his small intestine.
They removed that
through surgery
and then we've
waited quite a while
to find out what the
biopsy results were,
because they said
it was either a very
common malignant tumor
or a very rare one.
If it was a very rare one,
that was going to be very
tough news, bad news.
But it turned out it
was the common one.
The surgery was successful,
and we're just going
to wait and see
what the oncologist says,
if there's anything
else we need to do.
But judging by the way that
these tumors usually go,
he should be fine.
And I would say about 12
days after the surgery,
he made this
remarkable turnaround,
and all of a sudden he was back
to being his very athletic,
affectionate, silly self,
and so we're thrilled.
Thanks for asking.
- Yeah.
Do you ever find that when
you post pictures of Jasper,
or just any of the
personal stuff,
that in a way people care a
lot more about that than just,
sort of, you know,
what Dana might
think about Congress
voted two votes extra this way,
that way, the other thing.
Like, there is some
other connection,
and I think this is in some ways
partly what the book's about.
Like, that people
want something else
beyond just the
bludgeoning of politics.
- Yeah, and one of
the things that I,
you know, I have a rule.
No politics at the dog park.
Animals, our love for them,
our dominion over them,
is something so special in life.
And I grew up on a ranch.
So all the animals were special,
but the dogs and the
horses were really special.
You have that
connection with them,
that eye contact, that love.
I guess some people feel
that way about cats too.
Can't say I ever had
the same experience,
though I grew up
with cats as well.
- Yeah.
- But I do find
that there is a way
to connect with people that,
you know, like
Donna Brazil and I.
We've been friends
for a long time,
ever since hurricane Katrina.
And she worked with
the Bush administration
on restoring New Orleans,
but we really bonded
over our dogs.
And we both had different
dogs, our previous dogs,
when we first knew each other.
Sort of like you
and me in a way.
And then, you know,
dogs, unfortunately they don't
live as long as we would like.
And then the best way to heal
your heart is to
get another dog.
So I think it's been good,
and also this year has been
awful for so many reasons,
in terms of the pandemic,
but the fact that many
families have now,
or even single people, have
emptied the dog shelters,
and adopted dogs, as
I know you have done,
and advocate for adoption.
And I'll tell you,
I think that makes for
kinder people over time.
- Yeah, I'm with you. I
mean, you know the story.
I heard the lock
downs were happening,
and they were going to
put all these dogs down.
I ran to the shelter, they
had the things signed.
Clyde was being put down.
He was unnamed, unnamed dog
being put down that day,
and we snagged him,
and he's doing okay.
So before we get into the book,
let's talk a little
bit about just
kind of what's going
on in the world.
It's been a weird
year to say the least.
Well, actually,
let's talk about sort of
your former job for a second,
because press
secretary, Jen Psaki.
I've been giving her a bit
of a hard time on the show.
She doesn't seem particularly
well equipped to do this job.
She's always circling back.
Lot of non answers.
I suspect you've
got some sympathy--
- Look, a non answer is an art.
- (laughs quickly) And she's
perfected that art I suppose.
But I'm guessing you
have some sympathy.
- I have a different view.
Look, they've only been
in office for six weeks.
There is a lot you don't know,
and that's one of the reasons
you would want to circle back.
She does come to the job with
a lot more experience
than I had,
because she was
the spokesperson at
the State department
under President Obama.
And that gave her two things.
One, a deep dive
into foreign policy,
which a lot of people
don't necessarily have,
unless you've come
up through, you know,
that industry or
that department.
It takes a while to learn
all of those issues.
And she used to get
a really hard time
from a few reporters
in particular.
James Rosen was one of
them, from Fox News,
but Matt Lee of the
Associated Press,
he is an equal opportunity,
tough reporter on everybody.
And they used to have
a lot of tangles.
And remember,
she also got caught
up in that whole thing
of spying on James
Rosen and reporters.
So she comes to the job with
a little bit more experience
than many press
secretaries up to date.
The other thing is is she has
a press corps that is one.
There's not many
people in the room,
because they are very
strict on COVID protocol.
So there's probably, I think,
I think there was like 10
reporters total in the room?
That makes it for a
very different room.
Masks also, I think,
are a real barrier
to communication.
And even though somebody
might try to, like,
hold their mask away, you know,
there's this whole
thing going on
with you can't read lips,
you can't read expressions.
There's all of that.
And the other thing is,
I think President Biden is quite
happy not to drive the news.
And it's a weird thing,
because I think, well,
you have the opportunity.
Why don't you drive the
news every single day?
They seem to have this belief,
and we'll see how it
turns out for them,
that they can do their
jobs in a very steady,
easy way.
And I use that kind of phrasing
because that feels like the
pace of the administration.
- Is that partly just
because the media
kind of likes them
perhaps a bit more
than they liked
that Trump fella?
So, you know,
they're not going to
ride them as hard,
it makes their job
a little bit easier.
- I have a different
way of answering this.
And I haven't thought
of this until just now,
because I haven't
really been asked.
But if you think back to
the press secretaries,
everyone kind of represents
their boss very well.
Right?
So think of Ari Fleischer,
Tony Snow and me,
Scott McClellan.
We had the confidence
of George W. Bush.
You think of the
press secretaries,
even though Sean Spicer was not
press secretary for very long,
he continues to be a part of
President Trump's sort of orbit,
I would say.
The other press secretaries,
Stephanie Grisham, a
little bit different.
She never briefed, that might
be a little bit different one.
But I think that Jen Psaki is
just kind of in the approach,
tone, attitude of Joe Biden.
And so maybe what you want
from a press secretary, one,
you might want some
more answers, always,
but you also to know
that what you are getting
from that press secretary is
what the president is thinking,
and how he thought about it,
how they got to that decision.
I think that she's
actually doing that.
- Yeah.
Do you sense that
Biden is actually
in charge of this operation?
Because it doesn't
really seem like he is.
- I mean, I hear
what you're saying.
But I remember so many times,
do you remember how
they said that Karl was,
Karl Rove, was Bushes brain,
or that really Dick
Cheney was really
the one in charge of everything.
It wasn't true.
And I think about
this now, you know,
the other day when
they did the attack
on the Iranian forces in Syria.
Did you see the news
that they didn't
tell Kamala Harris until after?
- Mhm.
- So, to me,
I think, yeah.
I think that he is in charge.
- Yeah.
When you see something
like that get leaked,
not that they did the attack,
but that the Vice
President didn't know--
- That they didn't tell her?
- Yeah.
What do you make
of that process?
Because it seems to me that
there's gotta be something
going on there that
allows that to get,
like, that's the
story in an odd way,
more than, you know,
bombing a random caravan.
I think you're with me.
- I love talking to you,
because nobody else
has brought that up.
Yes, okay.
This Biden team has been
the most tight-lipped,
disciplined, no leaks,
no backbiting.
I mean, people
are kind of bored.
Like, wait,
we used to get, what happens,
even in any
administration you would
get a little bit of that.
But on the campaign trail,
they were very disciplined.
And I think that's
probably because
they keep their
circles so small,
but really pretty interesting
that even as it grew
from the primary campaign
into the general election,
still no leaks,
hardly any background,
you didn't get any color,
like, what's going
on over there?
About three weeks ago I said,
you'll know that
there's some tension,
or a little bit of elbow room,
when you start seeing
background quotes
from somebody close
to the White House,
or within the White House,
who says something
about Kamala Harris
that would make it clear that
she is the Vice President.
- [Dave] Mhm.
- And so when I saw that,
I'm like, ooh. To me,
that was kind of like,
it was kind of the
first time you had
seen a little bit of
a brush back pitch.
And I don't know what's
going on internally,
'cause you'd never see anybody.
They don't talk, they
don't do anything.
But that was definitely a
little bit of a just remember.
And also if I were Kamala
Harris, I'd be mad.
And then how it
happened is you have
West wing versus
Vice-President's office.
There's always a
little tension there.
Even though they handled
it pretty well so far,
and Joe Biden is actually quite,
I'm gonna say solicitous,
but he tries to be very
inclusive of Kamala Harris.
So even though he is the
President, he will say,
I did this, and he'll
stop himself and say,
we did this.
And I think that's a
little bit out of respect,
and also maybe just
his management style,
that he wants it to look
like there's a team,
and a shared effort.
I think time will tell.
It's it's a little early to say.
- So while you're giving
these guys credit on sort of
the competency of how
they're managing the thing,
how do you think we're doing
on the unity and healing front.
That was the meme we got
starting on January 1st.
Well, really I
guess on the 20th,
but really it's starting
at the top of the year.
It was like, okay,
2020 is gone.
Now we can begin the year
of unity and healing.
That was the
messaging for awhile.
We're not really hearing
about it anymore,
but I never felt that
it really had any value,
because we know if the shoe
had been on the other foot,
this certainly wouldn't have
been about unity and healing.
- And the bipartisan effort to
try to do a COVID relief plan
that they are now calling
the American rescue package.
That was, like
the whole idea was
that we're gonna
do this together.
And pretty quickly it
was clear that Ron Klain,
who was the Chief of Staff,
is not for that at all.
Again, there's a little bit of
color from the meeting that,
you remember when several
of those Republicans,
Susan Collins, Romney,
Portman, about seven of them.
They'd go to the
Oval Office to have
a meeting with Joe Biden to say,
hey, look.
You say 1.9 trillion,
we say 600 billion.
Let's talk, like maybe we
can figure out some things.
And Susan Collins, the
Senator from Maine,
reports that during
that entire meeting
Ron Klain sat to the
President's side,
out of eyesight from Biden,
shaking his head the
whole time like nope.
Nope.
And she said she
knew in that meeting.
She was like,
they have no intention of
making this a bipartisan effort.
Of course they
would love for some
for some Republicans to say,
oh yeah, sure.
Okay, we'll do that.
It's interesting, unity.
In any general election,
you can find that a
majority of people,
the vast majority
of people will say
they want Congress
to work together,
to get along, to do the
right thing together,
and move the country forward.
And then that lasts
for about three days.
In this case, it didn't
even get there at the time.
So it looks like we're
going to get $1.9 trillion
of spending by a very slim
majority of Democrats.
And I don't think
that you'll get
I don't think you'll
get any Republicans
to vote for it in the end.
- So as someone that worked
in the government and had to,
like, manage
messaging and stuff.
When they come up
with these numbers,
okay, we want 600 billion,
we want 1.9 trillion,
blah, blah,
blah.
It's like, doesn't it
all kind of feel made up?
Like where are these
numbers really coming from?
Who's really paying
for it, like,
that there's never a cost.
There's never a
cost to be, like,
I'm the guy that wants
to cut some stuff,
so you'd never do it,
or there's never a
benefit in other words.
Like, I'm going
to cut some stuff,
no one's going to really
give you a credit.
People just want more, and more,
and more, and more.
- Yeah, so you imagine
that Ron Klain would say,
we can do $1.9 trillion,
but don't you dare think
about going to $2 trillion,
because $2 trillion
into the year is like,
that's why things cost
$9.99 at the store.
They don't cost $10,
'cause you'd be like,
well, I'm not gonna pay $10.
But $9.99?
That's reasonable.
And I think what
the Democrats think,
the more you look at this bill,
there's very little that's
specific for COVID relief,
and they have a
particular philosophy,
and they're sticking to it.
They think that
the stimulus bill
that Obama passed in
2009 was way too small,
and that it did not do
enough to help the economy,
and that was one of the
reasons that they say
that the economy stalled.
They don't talk
about the regulations
that they put on businesses,
all of the things that
they were trying to do
to engineer the
economy as the problem.
They think that not
passing more stimulus
in 2009 was what hurt Obama.
And Ron Klain came
into this saying
that we are not going
to go too small,
that the danger
of going too small
is worse than the risk
of spending too much.
That's our position.
But if you start going
through this bill,
I just read this piece today
by Isaac Shore in
National Review.
There's a provision in there for
federal employees
to be given $21,000,
additional,
if their children have had
to do school from home,
and that's been a
hardship for them.
It's outrageous.
You check that out, I mean.
- Swamp, I think that's
what we call the swamp.
Is that what we call the swamp?
- That is so much the swamp.
Isaac Shore in National Review,
check that one out.
There's the things,
like the hundred
million dollars for
the bridge that Chuck
Schumer wants in Canada.
There's the hundred million
dollars that Nancy Pelosi
wants for that
transportation project,
from San Francisco
out to Silicon Valley,
where I thought everybody
was working from home now.
So why do we need that?
- Actually, they've
all moved to Miami.
That's the real truth.
- Right, so that they
could save on taxes.
- Yeah.
- There is so much
in this bill that has
nothing to do with COVID relief.
And what, think back
to what happened,
what was born out of the
stimulus package in 2009.
The Tea Party.
You know, they got the
grassroots attention.
I have a feeling that this
could be the same thing.
Now I also absolutely believe
that there are many people
who have suffered
in this pandemic
through no fault of their own.
A lot of restaurant
owners, waitresses,
people that worked
in hospitality,
and we could target
specific money to them.
But you go through this,
and it is a big wishlist.
And part of the thing
is that Republicans
disagreeing amongst each other,
that's normal.
It's going to happen,
but that is like
catnip for reporters.
They're always going
to report on that.
They don't do it as
much with the Democrats,
though they have lots of
differences amongst themselves,
but Republicans have
not really been able
to figure out a way to drive
a message about this bill.
And I don't know how you
feel about this, Dave,
but the legislation
as written has
a 73% approval rating
across the country.
- Well, I think,
to me, it's just that people
don't know what's in anything.
It's sort of what you're
saying. And it's like, oh,
you see a high number,
so you're like,
oh, I kind of don't know
where the money comes from,
but I guess it
doesn't come from me,
and they'll just take
it from somewhere.
And then if it's a high number,
that means I'll get more.
So no politician ever
wants to be the one.
Well, I guess there's
probably one guy
that kind of does it
every now and again,
which is Rand Paul is
the one guy that's like,
oh, maybe we can't
pay for all of this,
or maybe we shouldn't be
doing all of this stuff.
And that's just sort
of how politics works.
- And then you
sound mean if you--
- Right, then you're
mean and cold.
- That's right.
- Then you hate people--
- And we're about to see, like,
right after this,
they're going to pass a
infrastructure bill too.
And it will be
probably $4 trillion.
- Do you think that
the Democrats basically
fundamentally
believe that you can,
at this point, that you can
just print money endlessly?
'Cause I just have come to that.
Like, they don't,
there's no economic
principle for any of this.
And by the way, it's not like
the Republicans are so great.
They, you know,
Trump cut taxes, and also
the budget exploded too.
So like, they're all guilty,
but I think more fundamentally,
it seems the Democrats believe
that you can just print,
print, print,
print money.
Which also makes their position
on taxes a little weird,
because then why
would you always
be raising taxes on the rich,
unless it's purely to
punish them, right?
If you can just print money
in an unlimited supply,
then why do you have
to punish people too?
Well, I guess if you,
if you just need an
enemy to point at.
But do you think that,
or is that all of
government at this point,
which is just, ah,
we'll just make up numbers
and just keep printing,
and you know,
we'll go as far as
we can til the end,
til we ride right off the cliff.
- Well, not only that,
but I don't think that
you have many people
in business telling them not to.
- Yeah--
- Right?
So who's standing
athwart saying no.
You know, a few congressmen,
and people on Fox News?
Probably not gonna,
they're not gonna cut it.
And Republicans are also guilty.
But, look.
The law of economics, it's
called law for a reason.
The laws of economics
haven't changed.
I think the Democrats
think they can print money,
but also I think that they think
they can tax their way
out of this problem.
But I'll tell you
one thing about that.
If you go back to Obama era,
and when the Bush tax
cuts were going to expire,
they actually kept them,
because economically
they knew that that would
actually hurt economic
growth even more,
raising taxes at that time.
So I don't know how they're
going to raise all this money,
and I hope, hope is not a plan.
- Yeah.
- You don't want your
accountant to be hopeful.
- Right.
- And that's what we're
dealing with right now.
- Right. So before
we get to the book,
I want to ask you
a little bit about,
you've had a couple of changes
kind of in your day to day,
shifting around your schedule,
and you're doing, like,
87 shows and all kinds of stuff.
But I also want to
ask you about Fox,
and kind of what's
going on over there,
because I still hear this
a lot when I go on Fox.
Like, there's a certain
amount of people
that are just sort
of pissed at Fox,
that a year ago were
not pissed at Fox.
Do you hear any of that?
Do you think any of
the criticism is legit?
- Not so much anymore, no.
I mean, obviously I
heard a lot about that,
you know, right
after the election,
but I think now that the new
administration is underway,
and there's a lot
of new programming,
fresh programming here at Fox,
there's kind of some
exciting programming.
Of course, you know,
in that seven o'clock hour
rotating hosts right now.
Lawrence Jones was
hosting this week.
Did a great job last night.
Trey Gowdy has been great.
Rachel Campos-Duffy was good.
Katie Pavlich.
I got so, like, wow, we
have a lot of talent here.
And so that's great.
My job changed in
that I was doing
The Daily Briefing with
Dana Perino at two o'clock,
which I loved, you know,
when you could
come on as a guest,
and then the five, which I've
done for nearly 10 years now.
Can you believe it?
10 years in July, 10
years years in July--
- That's crazy, that's
absolutely crazy.
- 'Cause Jasper's nine, that's
how I always keep track.
So we started in July of 2011.
So in December, just as
I'm finishing up this book,
just as the
election's, you know,
sort of behind us,
thinking I'll have
a relaxing time,
get COVID behind us
with these vaccines,
and I to get a call
saying, we have an idea.
Like, oh,
I love ideas, what's your idea?
And it was for me to
no longer do America's,
excuse me, The Daily Briefing,
but to co-anchor America's
Newsroom with Bill Hemmer,
from nine to 11 in the morning.
I was shocked, pleasantly so.
I love Bill Hemmer.
I actually am one
of those annoying
people that loves mornings.
I like doing that
news first of the day.
And I have to say,
so we've been doing
it since January 18th,
and it has been such a joy.
I love it.
And you know, we do a lot
more about California,
which I think we should.
I think as a nation we
should all be focusing
a little bit more on
the country as a whole,
and also in California.
I'd be curious, you know.
We're on nine to 11, so
that's six to eight your time.
I don't know what
time you all are
getting up and
watching any news,
but we're getting
some pretty good
feedback out of California.
Got some good numbers.
The harder thing for
me, I think right now,
is figuring out how to actually
manage the length of my day.
One of the things
I write about in
the book is about
work-life balance,
and time management, and
taking control of that,
and making good
personal decisions.
So having the 09:00
to 11:00 AM show,
which I get up at 4:30
AM to prepare for that,
then having those few hours
in between that and the five,
which I need at least
an hour and a half
to prepare for the five I think.
Maybe an hour, about
an hour and a half.
It's kinda hard to, like,
where else can you
find time to do things?
So that's been a
little bit difficult.
- Yeah.
So with your schedule
change, well,
first off, you know,
on the California part
and doing an earlier show.
You know, I tweeted
this the other day,
but we have something like 2
million out of the 1.5 million
necessary signatures
to recall Gavin Newsom.
And I'm pretty sure
that CNN has not
run a story on that yet--
- We covered it
quite a bit, yeah.
- Right, you would think,
no, you guys gave covered it.
That's my point, that
it's like Fox covers it,
but if you were just
watching mainstream media,
you would have no
idea that the governor
from the largest
state in the union,
the 10th biggest
economy in the world,
something like that, is
going to be recalled--
- Did you get enough signatures?
- So right now they
have about 2 million,
and they only needed 1.5.
We know that, because
it's a one party state,
when they're going
through all the signatures
they're going to pull
all sorts of craziness.
But I think having
500,000 extra,
and we still have about a
week, a week to get more.
So it's gonna happen.
But the fact that, like,
that just doesn't get
covered sort of shows you
why we're in such
a polarized world.
- Yeah.
And also just the economic
weight of California,
both for the good
and the bad, right?
If this COVID
relief bill passes,
I think California stands
to get $70 billion.
I mean.
- I'm sure we'll spend it well.
- I'm sure.
What I think is very
interesting about
the recall is the
bipartisan nature,
or the non, I sort of feel
like it's a non-partisan issue.
As I understand it,
a lot of those
signatures are being
driven by parents of kids,
that they want their
kids back in school.
And there's the
hypocrisy of the elites,
who can afford to put their
kids in private school
but keep the public
schools closed,
and the small business
owners, and the restaurants,
who are just, like,
fed up.
And that never made sense to me.
The closing of outdoor
dining in California?
That's insane.
- Dana, you know I'm in LA.
It's 80 and sunny
every single day.
Not only did we have
outdoor closed dining,
we're still the last state
that has closed indoor dining,
which at that--
- I mean, in New York you
can have 35% indoor dining.
- Right?
So New York, where it's
freezing cold right now,
you could have 35% indoor.
We have still closed outdoor.
I mean, and we know that
Gavin Newsom is still
going out to his dinners
and all of that craziness.
But alright, don't
get me started on LA,
'cause then this will try--
- Or you'll get recruited
to run for governor.
Watch yourself.
- We'll see, we'll see--
- Did you get asked?
- Look, let the recall happen.
You know, I think
I jokingly said it,
it might've been on your show.
I like kind of half said it like
six months ago that
I would maybe run.
And then everywhere I go
now, everybody asks me.
Let's get the guy recalled,
and then we'll go from there.
How about that?
- You would be a very
attractive candidate.
And I don't just
mean aesthetically,
but of course it's true,
but, you know,
Dave, we need people to
want to run for office.
And I can absolutely
understand--
- But why would, why would.
You know this.
Why would a good person want
to put up with the insanity?
To me, when for the
few minutes that
David and I have
really discussed it,
like, could I actually do it?
It's more about all of the
hard, not the management,
not about knowing the ideas,
and what I would want to
do, and all that stuff.
It's about the horror
show related to the media,
and the destruction of personal
life, and everything else.
So as a person that would
clean that stuff up,
what kind of advice
would you give
someone that would
even consider it?
- Well, okay.
If you are going to do it,
one of the things
you have to do,
and like, if you're
serious about it,
you have to ask somebody with
competence, perhaps a friend,
to do a very thorough
opposition research dump
on you for your own
personal consumption,
and then you can
look at it and say,
oh yeah, that was,
yeah, that was done. Oh
yeah, I did. Oh right.
That wasn't very good.
You got to feel it.
And you have to see what it is.
You have to be very
honest with yourself,
because in today's day and age,
the competition is fierce.
You are going to face a lot of,
you know, negativity,
and people could bring
things up from your past.
A lot of women will shy away.
That's one of the
reasons that, like,
Elise Stefanik, the
Congresswoman from New York,
they focus specifically
on helping women
who think they want
to run for office,
but are concerned
about something
coming up in their past and
hurting their current family.
And they also are very
reluctant to ask to raise money.
That's one of I think the
hardest things that people have.
I think you might have a
hard time with that too.
You got to call up your
friends, and job on them,
and get them to give
you a million dollars
for your campaign
that might not win.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- And so that's hard.
But I do think that if people
are thinking about running,
if you have a
loving relationship,
a great family that is going
to stand by you no matter what,
you can do it.
You can get through it.
- I think I'm going to stick
on YouTube for now, for now.
Unless you're looking
to get back in the game,
and if you want to be my
Chief of Staff or something,
then we can go from there--
- I'd be a very
good Chief of Staff.
I would not be a good candidate.
I'd be a great Chief
of Staff though.
I'd be like Ron Klain
in the background,
going nope, nope.
- Yeah, Exactly.
Exactly. So let's shift
to your book a little bit,
because you were talking about
sort of your schedule change,
and managing your life
and everything else.
And when I was reading
through this this morning,
and I've got it
right here, I had,
there's a certain sort of
Jordan Peterson feel to this,
about getting your
life in order.
But, you know,
you're obviously aiming this
more towards young women.
Now you say, you say from
a former young woman.
Am I allowed to ask a TV
host how old they are?
Is that a question
that can be asked?
- Sure, I know.
So I love the subtitle, it
makes me laugh every time.
And I also think it's true,
so I'll be 49 this year.
So--
- That's like, you're
still pretty young.
- Kind of.
But you think about people,
like, what do you
learn from, say 22,
when you start your first job,
to 49 is a lot.
You know, you go through a lot.
And I get asked by a lot of
younger people for advice
as they're trying to climb
their way up the ladder,
or try to get their
sort of life together.
And so I wrote the book,
because all those young
women that come in my office,
I could do it all day long.
I could have a
mentoring business
just sitting here taking calls,
giving advice.
But I just noticed that
they would worry so much,
and they want a specific plan,
which specific
plans do not exist.
You can put yourself
in the right direction.
So when I say in the title
everything will be okay?
That is true,
but you have to do some
things to make it that way.
You have to make good personal
decisions, time management.
I think that there's a lot
of freedom in discipline,
and having some
principles and parameters
in your life that can help you,
but there's really ambitious,
amazing young people out there.
And especially for young women.
If you're born in
America, first of all,
you already won
life's great lottery.
- [Dave] Yeah, you're good.
- If you are an
educated American woman,
then all you got
to decide right now
is how responsible
do you want to be,
and how hard do
you want to work?
Because you're in
the driver's seat.
And I don't think a lot
of them realize that.
You know, a lot
of them think that
the guys are always going to
be promoted over the gals.
That's not true.
That the guys are going to get
the promotions and the raises.
Anymore, that's true.
Many women are now the primary
breadwinner of their families.
And so we're in a little bit
of a cultural shift there,
and it is time to step up.
To be a leader, to be a manager,
you got to show that you're
able and willing to do it,
and resilient.
The pandemic adds
another wrinkle.
How do you network
in a pandemic?
How do you get face
time with the boss?
How do you figure out
what your next move is?
So I talk about all sorts
of those things in the book.
- Yeah.
Do you think that the
pandemic did anything,
broadly speaking,
to women in a different
way than it did to men?
So perhaps being home
more, homeschooling,
whatever, you might be cooking,
all those things, again,
of course they're not
exclusive to women,
but as you know, because
I toured with Jordan,
I saw what so many young
men were dealing with.
And now this is more about what
young women are dealing with.
Throw in a pandemic where
everybody's back in the house,
and it's very different.
- Yes.
Some of the statistics
about how many women
have left the workforce
will just blow your mind.
That there are less women
in the workforce now
than there were some
like 30 years ago.
Now they'll come back.
That will come back.
But what do you lose
in that time frame?
Right?
Because new colleagues come,
new technology is introduced.
We have a new
software system here.
I don't even, I don't
even understand it.
But you have to get
trained on those things.
You come back to the workforce,
and all of a sudden they
want to cut your salary
by $10,000 because
you were at home.
Now what's happened is,
the reason a lot of women
had left the workforce
is because kids
aren't in school.
So if kids aren't in school,
it usually will fall to
the woman, the mother,
to be the one that
stays home to help
with the work from
home schedule,
sit on the Zoom, take
care of the family.
And women have made
a lot of sacrifices.
Men too, men too.
But from the workplace
perspective, yes.
If I could get one
piece of advice
that I talk about in the book.
A girlfriend of
mine was a global
talent officer
for a big PR firm,
and she has three boys.
And she's one of those
friends that I look at
as how in the world
does she do at all,
one of those friends.
So I asked her about
this issue with women.
Now this is true
regardless of the pandemic.
Let's say that
you're going to have
to take a break from work.
Whether it be because
of kids, work from home,
or maybe you decide
that you want to spend
the first few years
of your child's life
at home and not
at the workplace.
When you decide to go
back to the workplace,
it's almost always
true that women
will be looked at
as a difficult hire,
because they might not be
available all the time.
Work-share is a great idea,
and some of the companies
are doing it well.
The pandemic has
helped a little bit
to make for some
more flexibility,
but there will be a gap
in your resume, right?
So it'll be like, I worked here,
I worked here, but
then there's this gap.
And now you're coming
back to the workplace.
Oftentimes what Michelle told me
is that they will be demoted,
or cut in salary,
something like that.
So she has this
great recommendation.
I tell everybody about this,
and it's true for
same-sex couples too.
If you have a similar situation,
if you are going
to take some time
off from work to
help raise a baby.
She says, if you're
going to take time off,
start an LLC, little
small business,
easy to set up, pretty
inexpensive really.
And I don't know about
California prices
but I think in New
Jersey, it's like $250.
- I think Delaware.
You want to do it in Delaware.
- Good point.
And she said have
a little business.
So I would call mine, like,
Dana Perino Communications.
And you have a little
bit of opportunity
then to take on a client or two,
or a project here and there.
But when you go back
to the workforce,
you will not have a work gap.
You will have an entrepreneurial
addition to the resume,
so that the chances of
you being knocked back,
either from a responsibility
standpoint or salary,
is greatly decreased.
And I thought that
was such good advice.
I try to mention it always.
- So how much what
you have in the book
really is just sort of, like,
think about your life clearly,
because it seems to me
that a lot of young people,
especially because of what's
happened in the last year,
not only does the future
just look very murky,
like, the future of the country,
the future of their lives,
like, a career,
you know, any of
that kind of stuff.
But also they don't know, like.
what they want in a sense of,
like, young women,
maybe they've been
trained for too long
to put too much emphasis on
career instead of family.
Same could go for young men.
That where they're
always being aimed at.
Like, if you were a young
woman and you were just like,
I just want to be the
best homemaker and
wife that I can be,
and teach my kids,
and cook, and keep
a great house.
That's a very lofty thing.
My mom raised three kids--
- That's a job.
- She did not work when
she was raising us,
but then did go back
to work afterwards.
She worked before, and then,
but had like a 20
year gap on that
while she was
raising three kids.
To me, that was a
beautiful thing.
But like, if you say
that as a woman now,
it's kind of scoffed
at by the mainstream.
- Yes, though I think that's
changing a little bit.
I do, especially as women
now have more choices,
right?
So, as I mentioned,
a lot of women are now
the primary breadwinner.
So that's actually,
there's a cultural shift
happening there too.
Do you have a life partner
that is okay with that,
you know, and supportive?
And I think that that is
changing just a little bit.
I have a piece of
advice in there
that I call the
whiteboard incident.
And it's because of something
that Peter did with me.
When I was in San Diego,
when we lived in San Diego,
I really wanted to work
for George W. Bush.
I wanted to get back
to Washington DC,
where I had worked before.
Didn't quite know how to do it.
I was working in PR.
Really didn't enjoy it.
And I couldn't really
see how to get ahead.
And we lived in San Diego,
which is where everybody
would love to live,
except you're in LA,
that's the other place
people want to live.
- (laughs quickly) San Diego
sounds pretty sweet these days
compared to what's
going on in LA--
- Yeah, and the mayor,
Kevin Faulkner, did a pretty
good job there during COVID,
and he could be your competition
if you run for governor.
- I know, I know.
- So I went to DC, I
met with a few people,
networked with folks that I used
to work with on Capitol Hill.
At that time, it
was August of ninth,
I'm sorry, August of 2001.
And then most of the
jobs were filled,
but they'd keep
an eye out for me.
And I come home and think I
just really want to do this.
So Peter says, let's
do an experiment.
He gets the whiteboard out with
this little erasable marker.
And he says, tell me all the
things you want to do in a job.
So I listed the things
I like to do in my work.
Tell me all the things you
don't want to do in a job.
So I listed all of those things.
And then we assigned a
value to those things.
And then it became very
clear, you add it up.
Staying in San Diego
was like a zero.
Doing anything in
DC was like a nine.
I'm like, oh,
when you look at it that way.
Interesting.
I also mentored a young
woman not too long ago,
and she was sort of following
in the footsteps of her family,
of medical professionals.
And at the end of
the chat, I said,
if you weren't going to do
this, what would you do?
She goes, oh,
I am so into psychology,
and I bought these books, and
I've read all these things,
and I've been listening
to the podcasts,
and I was thinking about
getting a Master's degree,
because I've just
so interested in it.
I said, well wait,
Maybe you should be doing that.
(laughing)
Right?
- [Dave] Right, right.
- And so there's just so
much freedom now for people
to be able to do so
many different things.
One last story I'll mention.
There's a young woman
that I know who graduated
in December of 2019
in event management.
Okay.
She gets a job, she's
here in New York,
she's going to do events.
And she was working
for a company
that did events
all over the city,
big events, like
runway type things,
fashion week, things like that.
And what happens in February of,
the end of February
2020, no events.
I think that we are
now on our one year
anniversary of our
two week lockdown.
(laughs quietly)
- [Dave] Yep.
- So she lost her job.
She also ended up
with a skiing injury,
so she went home to
live with her parents.
And she could have
been quite despondent,
but she was watching
these nurses and doctors,
and she knew that in
her area, in New Jersey,
they needed more masks.
Her mother or grandmother was an
interior designer
who had retired,
and she had all
this extra fabric.
So she had a sewing machine
and she's kind of hands on,
so while she was recovering
from her surgery,
she just made
masks all day long.
Making masks,
donating them around.
But they were super cute.
So then people were like,
where can I get one of those?
Where can I?
So she started
selling the masks,
and then she ended up with so
much business that she hired
a couple of other young
women to work for her,
and then she bought
an embroidery machine,
and now she's been doing that.
And who knows if she'll ever
go back to event management.
You know, she found
a whole new thing,
and I love the resilience
and the spirit.
And also she was unconditionally
loved by her family.
And it's okay to rely on your
family in times like this.
- Yeah.
And that's one of the things
that's been so hard for people,
because in many
cases we're seriously
separated from our family.
I actually haven't seen my
parents since this began,
because they finally
just got the vaccines,
and, you know,
they're in their early 70's,
so it just wasn't
going to happen--
- Me too.
- I'm finally gonna see
them in a couple of weeks.
- Good.
- But just lose,
I think losing that connection,
'cause, you know,
people think it can be
replaced by FaceTime and Zoom,
and it just can't.
- No. And the other thing
that's happened for a lot of
young people when you're
on zoom all the time
is there's a lot of anxiety
about your appearance.
Obviously I'm in
full hair and makeup
from the show I did
earlier from Fox News,
and so this is not how
I would normally be
if I was working from my office,
and I wasn't on TV.
The anxiety about performing
and being on camera
all the time.
You think of a lot of people
are kind of introverts, right?
Zoom gets them way out
of their comfort zone.
If you have to be on a Zoom
for three hours a
day with your team,
it's been hard on
a lot of people.
And also presenting in
front of that many people,
instead of just doing it
in front of your team,
or your board, in the
meeting and conference room.
Now you're doing it
in front of everybody.
And that anxiety
about public speaking
is something that
I also talk about,
especially because one
thing that's different
from anything that you and
Jordan would have talked about.
One of the things,
one of the pieces of
advice I give is you,
women have to find
their strong voice.
So we have a naturally
higher register.
For some, especially on a Zoom,
or on camera,
the voice can be grating.
And a lot of young
women get into
this habit early on
from their teens,
and it's kind of following
them into the workplace,
with, I call it up speak.
Talk like this 'cause they're
not really sure
about all the things.
We used to call it
valley girl talk.
- Yeah.
- I'm just telling you,
you will not get promoted,
or chosen to go
meet the new client,
or go on the big business
trip if you talk like that.
And a lot of people, Dave,
they don't even realize
that they're doing it.
And if you can gently
point out to them
that they're speaking this way,
they'll turn it
around immediately.
They can turn it off.
It's like, well,
I do that? I didn't
know I do that.
And then when they get
with their friends,
they could fall back into it.
But I'm really,
really big on this,
because I see it.
I'm like, oh,
if she doesn't stop
that, she's never,
never going to get promoted.
- But that's like,
that's like one of the
ones that it's kind of
hard to say to somebody
these days, right?
'Cause it feels like an
affront to their very being,
the way you sound,
the way you speak.
- Yeah, maybe there
will be an HR violation.
(laughs quietly)
- Yeah.
No, that's what I mean.
Like they're going to, yeah,
This is my natural affect.
- But I've taken a couple
of young women aside,
and you can make it
kind of light, sweet.
I feel like we have an
obligation to help them.
If you have someone
in your life,
if it's your daughter,
or your granddaughter,
or your niece, or somebody
that works for you.
Maybe don't even tell them,
just get them the
book (laughs quickly),
and let them see.
Hopefully they'll come
to it on their own.
But I'm telling you, I
know that this has worked.
There's a young woman
who used to work for me
who definitely used to do that.
I also think it's a sign
of a lack of confidence,
because if you say something
in the form of a question,
then you don't have
to own the opinion.
Do you see what I mean?
Like, I don't know.
I'm just asking questions.
If you say it that way,
you don't have to own it.
- Yeah.
I thought it was a really
interesting part of the book,
because it reminded
me of sort of why
I can't stand listening to NPR,
because they do that thing too,
and everything sort of
sounds like a question,
and like it's never a
definitive proclamation,
and I can't stand it.
- Yeah.
I mean, actually I don't listen
to NPR for a lot of reasons.
(laughs quickly) Now
that you say that--
- That's one of
many, many reasons.
Yeah.
- No, but now that you say
that, morning edition, Yeah.
On morning edition then.
Yeah, and even when
they ask the question--
- That tone.
- Yeah, even when they
asked the question
and they know what
the answer is,
they still do it.
You know what I mean?
Like, it's all scripted.
- It's the worst
kind of scripted.
So I was really interested
in chapter four,
because it's how do
you find a role model?
And as you may remember,
chapter nine of my
book was find a mentor.
- Yep, yep.
- And that was
not a chapter that
I had intended to
put in my book,
but what happened
with me and Jordan
was sort of an accidental
mentorship, I suppose,
because we happened to
be on tour together,
and it just kind of happened.
But that you made a point of
saying, how do you find it,
like this is something
that you've got to do.
Do you think everybody needs
a mentor, needs a role model?
- Yes I do.
But I don't think
that the relationships
have to be as formal as
some people might think.
A lot of companies now will have
these formal mentoring programs,
and that's great.
Although sometimes I don't
think they're really working.
Like, I know of this
one program where
there's somebody that
works in production,
and they've been paired with
somebody who works
in accounting,
but the person, that
just doesn't really work.
Now it's good to meet
people around the office,
and I'm big on networking,
and building your network,
and meet as many
people as you can.
But I, yes,
I absolutely think that
you need role models.
I think back to my childhood.
I really wanted to be an
anchor, a news anchor.
I love Diane Sawyer.
She had worked in the
Nixon White House.
A lot of people
don't remember that.
I liked how she carried herself,
her story telling,
her journalism.
I thought she had such
gravitas and dignity.
I also even thought of, this
is a fictional character,
but I love Cybill
Shepherd in Moonlighting.
- Oh yeah!
Bruce Willis.
Yeah, yeah--
- She was the boss lady.
And I was sort of
like, you know,
there's a saying in
women's mentoring called,
or that says you have
to see her to be her.
That's another reason, you know,
I like to do the mentoring.
So I'm constantly
finding role models.
I have one now that I
write about in the book,
her name is Ann Gloag.
She's now Dame Ann
Gloag, I should say.
I should say a
self-made business woman
in Scotland who has
the biggest heart,
and as her company, Stagecoach,
the busing company,
as it's grown
internationally, she got the,
her brothers and her split
it up, the responsibilities.
So they expanded into Europe.
She did Europe and Africa,
and her brothers did
Asia and South America.
So she went to Africa.
She had been a nurse in a,
they call it in England
a burns unit for,
I don't know what we
would call it here.
I don't think we
have a specific name.
But she treated people that
had wounds from burns and fire.
She goes to Africa.
First of all, she
refuses to pay bribes.
Will not do it.
And this has never happened
before in the busing contracts
that are happening in
Kenya and Tanzania,
and they said, well,
then your buses are not going
to be released from the port.
And she says, fine,
and we'll make sure
that you're blamed.
She is tiny.
I'm short, I'm five,
I think just a little
smaller than me,
really, really small person.
She's got such guts.
But what I really also love
about her is her heart.
She saw what was happening
for early childhood
development and maternal
health in Africa,
and she was just determined
to do something about it.
So not only is she just a
terrific business woman,
I feel like she
has such a gracious
way of handling her time,
her work-life balance,
where she gives a ton
with accountability.
You know, nobody
gets the free money,
but she has a few clinics and
an orphanage that she runs.
She runs the
business, and she has,
I think, six children,
and then several that
she's adopted from Africa.
And I see her as sort of a,
not a peer role model,
but, you know,
even somebody that's
a former younger woman
can have role
models to this day.
'Cause I always want
to be improving.
That's why I listened
to, you know,
I watch your show, I
listen to podcasts,
I am constantly reading.
I don't ever want
to stop learning.
And meeting her and
getting to know her
has really enriched my life.
- Wait, Dana,
are you telling me you
don't know it all at 49?
You haven't perfected
the whole thing?
(laughs quickly)
You haven't done it yet?
- I don't know if
you're like this.
I feel like I wake up every day
knowing less than I
knew the day before.
I feel like the
universe of knowledge
is just growing
so exponentially.
I feel I have so much to learn.
I never feel like
I have read enough.
And usually I have read more
than anybody else in the room,
but I always feel like
I'm a little bit behind.
- I asked my friend
who, as you know,
recently passed, Larry King.
Many times I asked
him, you know,
what did he think the
meaning of life was?
And he always said
the same thing.
The only thing I know
is that I do not know.
- I do not know.
I just read a book by Adam
Grant called Think Again,
The Power of Knowing
What You Don't Know.
- Mhm.
- That was great.
And it kind of takes
some pressure off.
You can say said, like,
I don't know about, I'm curious.
Let me learn.
Talk to me, tell
me what you know.
How do you see it?
How do you feel about it?
And that kind of approach
I think can help,
going back to what we started
with in terms of unity.
You know,
Barbara Bush had a
saying that in a marriage
both people needed to be willing
to go 60% of the way there.
And I don't know if in
our public discourse,
and in our public
policy debates,
both sides aren't there yet.
They're not willing to
go 60% of the way there.
And I don't know what will
help us get to that point.
I don't know what
the issue will be
that will help get us there.
- Yeah.
I mean, unfortunately,
it's almost like it has to
sort of be something terrible.
Like, that's the only way we
could kind of come together.
Like the way New York
was after nine 11, like--
- Yeah, 'cause even the
pandemic didn't really do it.
- No.
If anything, it
exacerbated this stuff.
Let's talk about the
last chapter though.
I feel like that would
be a good way to wrap.
It's called 'Serenity:
how can you detox, recover,
and find peace?'
I feel like pretty
much everyone's
looking to find a
little peace these days.
That, you know,
we're home more,
we're online more,
social media is not
making us social.
The quest for peace
doesn't seem to be going
that well for a lot
of people right now.
- Well, so I wrote that chapter
because the serenity prayer
was prominent in my home
growing up as part of
the Lutheran church.
But also my mom went
through a program
called Children of Alcoholics.
So that's part of the AA system,
and the serenity prayer is
very important for recovery.
And I've known a
few people that have
gone through
Alcoholics Anonymous.
Bob Beckel,
one of the first people
on The Five, he did,
and it really helped
turn his life around.
When I think about serenity,
do you know those moments, Dave,
in your life,
and they're usually
just glimpses,
when you feel like
you're right exactly
where you're supposed
to be at the moment.
- They're rare and
they're fleeting.
- It's such a gift.
And I feel like that's
what God's intention was,
for us to be able to
have more of that.
And when I mentor
these young women,
I find that they're
nowhere close
to being able to find that.
So I have lots of
different suggestions
in that chapter for how
somebody might find it.
It's just some things
that work for me.
I write a lot of lists,
and if I feel like I'm
being concerned with,
consumed with worry or anxiety,
on a piece of paper I will write
my list of concerns and worries,
and then I'll make two columns.
And that next column I'll say,
is this something that I
have control over or not.
Mark it.
For the things that
I have control over,
I then in the third
column make a little bit
of a notation about what
I could do about it.
And then I learned this exercise
when I was in college
and pretty stressed.
I take that piece of paper,
and I carry it with
me in my purse,
in my backpack, my back pocket,
wherever it might be,
so that when I feel that
sort of anxiety bubbling up,
I can pull that back
out and look at it,
and know, okay,
wait, wait.
Okay.
I've got a plan here for how
to deal with those things.
I've also found that
guided meditation
for me has been very useful.
And then I would
say one other thing,
which is, as you said,
we're quite isolated
and we're on the Zooms.
And even though I
love the connection,
I love being able to talk to you
and to see you like
in the Jetsons.
- Yeah.
(laughs quickly)
No, well that's the irony of it,
right? It's like, I
didn't even know you.
I don't think I had ever,
I knew who you were
obviously for many years,
but I don't think I had
done your show until,
no, maybe I, no, we did
do it in person once,
a little bit before lockdown--
- You were in town,
you were in the city.
- But in essence, we became
friends through this thing,
which is a very weird, you know.
We've never had
a drink together.
a meal together--
- Oh, let's fix that.
Do you know what would
really help in Washington?
I feel like everyone needs
to go and get drunk together,
with no phones.
But like, imagine,
you know, you could imagine,
you know, Ted Cruz getting drunk
with Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez,
they'd probably
strike up a friendship
and maybe be able to
get to that unity.
But anyway,
the other thing that I started
doing a couple of years ago
was an exercise to get
out of my own mind,
because something that I
remind people of here is
just when you think
everybody's thinking about you,
and you think that they're
thinking negatively about you,
you have to remember no
one's thinking about you.
They are thinking
about themselves.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And also I remember
everybody's going
through something.
Everybody.
Look, Dave,
you're going through something.
My sister's friend,
she is going through,
she just had a
double mastectomy.
Thankfully it looks like
cancer free, you know.
Peter and I are going
through something.
Everybody's going
So what I started doing is,
anybody that I see
that I'm walking by,
or on the subway when I
used to take the subway,
people that I won't
necessarily say hi to,
I'll just say a little
prayer for them.
So like, I remember this
one lady and her daughter.
They were doing homework on
the subway on the way home.
And I remember, like,
please help them
get home safely.
To the guy, I hope that he has
a really productive day at work.
I hope that she is treated
well by all of her colleagues.
I hope nobody, the guy
that works in retail,
I can't stand it
when anybody is mean
to anybody that works
in customer service.
And really like, I pray that
nobody's bad to him today,
or like negative
towards him today.
And it kind of
became a habit that,
it really helps me get
out of my own head,
get out of my own way,
and to sort of
spread this kindness,
because I really think that
that's the way to reduce anxiety
and increase your ability
to be your full self
that will hopefully open up
opportunities and
doors for promotion,
raises, a change in career,
or even if you haven't met
that lucky somebody yet,
open your heart up to meeting
somebody and making
a commitment.
- Well, Dana,
that's the perfect ending,
but I have to return the
favor that you often offer me,
which is to bring
Clyde on your show--
- Oh, that's Sam.
- No, no,
I don't need to bring Clyde on.
This is my show.
Is Jasper around, or?
- No, I'm at work.
But hold on, I'm going
to get something.
Hold on.
(laughing)
So I went on that book
tour with my Jasper book,
and I bought one of these.
This is--
- Oh, there you go.
- This is felt Jasper.
You gotta get a few of these.
Get a felt Clyde, oh.
They're the best toys.
Only thing is Jasper
really wants to eat this.
- Well, Jasper should be
allowed to eat Jasper--
- He wants this toy.
They're kind of expensive,
but if you go on Etsy,
you can send them a
picture of your dog
and they'll make you one.
Even has like a little ear.
- What a world, what a world.
- Dave, you're a great American,
and a wonderful person.
Thank you.
- Right back at you.
The book is Everything
Will Be Okay,
and everything will be okay.
It really, it really will be.
- It will be.
- I look forward to seeing
you in person and good luck--
- Catch a drink.
- I was about to say good luck
with the rest of the book tour,
but good luck
sitting in that seat
talking to other people
like me I suppose.
- Thanks Dave.
- Okay, bye-bye.
If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full
episode playlists,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.